こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
おそらく　ほぼ100％
この家にねずみがいます
下に編集部屋があるんですけども
編集部屋で僕一人でずっとボーとしてたら
物をたくさん入れる棚の
下の部分からたまに
ごとごと　ごとごと　ドンドン
て聞こえるんですよ
はい　ねずみ
ねずみ確定です
間違いなくねずみ確定
念には念を入れて
ひょっとしたらすごい
巨大なねずみかもしれないし
小さいねずみかもしれない
どんなねずみにも対応できるように
今日は超巨大なねずみ捕りを
仕掛けたいと思います
はい　こちら
プロ企画ネズミ捕りネズミ禁止区域GB
ネバネバでねずみを
捕まえるってやつなんですけども
ピーナッツのにおいでおびき寄せます
毒性のある成分は一切不使用
すごいぞ　これはもうくっついたら
取れませんからね
今日は！ 一箱に10枚はいてるんですけど
ネズミ捕りを40枚準備して
ま　巨大かもしれないけど
たぶんねあの音はね
絶対巨大なんですよ
たぶん巨大なんで今回は
巨大ネズミ捕獲大作戦ということで
ネズミ捕りをちょっと集中的にでかい
でかい　そのねずみを捕まえる場所を
作って巨大ねずみが
来るのを待って必ず今日
捕獲しようと思います
どんなサイズのねずみが
くるかも分かんないんですけども
おそらくは
超巨大サイズのねずみが
出てくるんじゃないでしょうか
いざ　捕まえるっ！！
参るっ！！　あっ
ここ周辺を狙って捕まえようと思います
たぶん出入りするのは玄関だからな
たぶん通るとしたら玄関のほうで確実に
外からの入り口だから
捕まえるなら多分
玄関付近だと思います
セットしていきましょう
うっあっあっぁあーーー！！！
はい　というわけで玄関は
制覇できました
これで多分ねずみが
外から入ってきた時でも
どっかしらに引っかかって
動けなくなる筈です
では　ねずみが
来るのを待ちましょう！
そもそもネズミ取りが
効果あるかどうかという話っすよ
なんかめっちゃちゃっちいくて
効果がなさそうな気がするんですよ
だって　これだけでこんなのに
ねずみが捕まるらしいですよ
ほんとかな
あっあっあっあ
やっやばいやばいやばいやばい
待ったまった　やばいやばい
待って　待って
やばいやばいやばいやばい...
[笑]　納豆かって
やばいやばい
取れない 取れない 取れない
うわ　やば！
マジだ　これどうしよう
落ちない　落ちない
無理無理無理
ねぇ　俺終わったじゃん　手
ねえ　まって俺これやばいじゃん
アゴマウス）チュウチュウチュウ
ぁチュウチュウチュウチュウチュウチュウ
アゴマウス）おう！久しぶりはじめくん
暗...
はじめの家は　飯が
たくさんだな！
ぁチュウチュウチュウ
ぎゃっぴーー
あんっ
捕まったチュウ
チュウチュウチュウ
チュウチュウチュチュチュウ
チュ？
チュウー
は）出たな　巨大ネズミめ...
ア）ネズミじゃねぇ
ネズミ取り？
は）捕まえたぞ〜！
ア）ありがと
ええこれまじのネズミ捕り？
は）いや！ちょっと
ねぇー　まっ！！＃＄％＠＋＆＆＄＃
チュチュチュチュチュ
は）はぁねーまってあ...
ア）HAHAHAHAHA
は）すげえ大ネズミだ
大ネズミが捕まった
アゴマウスの心）うわ　やられたー
アになりきったは）もう悪させんとこって
ア）いや悪さしてねえよ
ア心）もう悪させんとこ
あ...ほ！
HOHAHO！
てれれれれれれれ
てーーてれれれーれーれれー
てれれれー
てれれれーれー
てれれれーれーれれ
てれれれーれーれーー
て・て・て・TEN★